What up, what up, what up, herzlich willkommen zur neuen Folge des Podcasts Ufo mit Stieftitz. Hey, ich bin auch wieder dabei. Aufgeladen, die Gag-Kanone ist geladen und entesichert, will ich sagen. Mir gegenüber sitzt der fantastische Florentin Will, herzlich willkommen auch. Herzlich willkommen, danke schön, nein, herzlich willkommen an dich, vielen Dank. Nein, herzlich willkommen an dich. Du hast mir heute so nett die Tür aufgehalten, Stefan, das hat mich echt gefreut, dass er selber von dir seht. Du, ich habe mich gefreut, dass du immer wieder da bist, dass du mir wieder reinschneißt und ich dann würde doppelt den Stimmenimitator senden, wie letzte Woche. Hat man gemerkt, der ist nicht so lustig, aber klingt exakt wie du, immer wieder lustig. Das ist so ein sehr, sehr alter, gesetzter Mann, der dann hier mal sitzt und deine Stimme nachmacht. Wir haben uns heute mal die ganzen Post-Einsendungen vorgenommen, die wir bekommen haben, denn wir haben einen Aufruf in die Welt hinausgeschrien, dass denn die ganzen jungen Damen, die sich mit diesem Podcast hier täglich rumschlagen müssen, uns mal schicken wir momentan kein Internet, um darauf zuzugreifen. Wir haben nämlich herausgefunden, dass uns mehr Männer hören. Ich habe fantastisches Internet. Und zwar hören uns 73 Prozent Männer, 41 Prozent, heute mal die Statistikfolge, 41 Prozent sind zwischen 25 und 34, 37 Prozent zwischen 18 und 24. Das sind unsere beiden grössten demografischen Beide. Entspricht das auch ungefähr dem Geschlechterverhältnis von dem Pokerabend, auf dem du am Wochenende warst? Der Pokerabend, auf dem ich am Wochenende war, war exakt zu 73 Prozent, zu 75% männlich. Ja? Ja, ich würde sagen, der war auch glaube ich zwischen 37%, zwischen 18 und 24 Jahre alt. Ich glaube, der ist ein exaktes Ebenbild für unsere Schriftstiftung. Ich glaube, das ist ein exaktes Ebenbild von jeder Gruppe an Menschen. Die meisten kommen aus Deutschland. Ja, wenn eine Gruppe nur gross genug wird, wird sie irgendwann immer in dieses statistische Bild fallen. Jo, und was grossartig ist, finde ich, wenn uns Leute hören, dann zu 42 Prozent hören sie direkt mehr als fünf Folgen. Oh wow. Wohingegen 30 Prozent hören nach einer Folge aber sofort auf. Aber sowas vor. Aber die hören dann nie wieder rein. Wow, aber das fliegt raus sofort. Aber das gibt es ja tatsächlich, also ich habe ja, nachdem ich auf der Frank-Intern-Master-Class war, hatten wir so eine kleine Produktionsfirma gegründet und wollten YouTube erobern. Und da gab es unendlich lange Diskussionen immer, was muss man genau machen, um auf YouTube erfolgreich zu sein. Jetzt mal unabhängig vom Content, wie tatsächlich die Qualität des Videos ist, gibt es da ja wahnsinnig viele Philosophien. Das ist ja wirklich so ein Feld mit Gurus, die dann irgendwie sagen, nein, es geht nur darum, dass die Interaction Rate wichtig ist, dass viele Leute kommentieren und Daumen nach oben, nee, das ist egal, hauptsächlich die schauen das Video bis zum Ende an, aber egal, ob sie kommentieren. Und da gibt es einfach tausend verschiedene Leute, die tausend verschiedene Philosophien haben, aber alle hundertprozentig sicher sind, dass ihre Version die beste ist. Und da kann man sich dann natürlich auch stark mit den Statistiken von YouTube beschäftigen. Und da gibt es dann die Detention Rate, also da siehst du genau, wann wie viele Leute dein Video angeschaut haben. Also es startet mit 100 Prozent und geht dann in der Regel runter, also ganz selten hoch, in der Regel geht es runter, je nachdem, so. Und dann kannst du halt schauen, okay, teilweise kannst du wirklich genau sehen, okay, ein Gag war schlecht und danach bricht die Quote ein. Das ist für uns sehr interessant.
Das ist mega interessant, aber teilweise ist es auch wirklich absurd, weil Leute wirklich so rapide schnell abschalten. Also wirklich, nach vier Sekunden bist du nur noch bei 80 Prozent und nach acht Sekunden bist du nur noch bei 70 Prozent. Also du denkst dir, was haben die Leute erwartet, dass in den ersten Sekunden passiert? Ich würde gerne mal sehen, was bei den Leuten, was die da machen, die ausgeschaltet haben, ob die nebenan, denen man wieder die heißesten Bikini-Fotos von Emma Stone oder so gesehen. Kann sein, ja. Und dann klicken die da rauf nachher. Aber ich habe auch mal so eine Kurve beim Fernsehen gesehen, beim ZDF, wo abends dann zwischen um 22 und 22 die Kurve aber rapide, also wie so ein richtig steil, fast senkrecht hinunter ging. Und da wurde ein Teaser der Heudeshow gezeigt. Und beim Teaser der Heudeshow rasten die Leute komplett aus. Die hassen das, die machen das weg sofort. Weil die Leute dann auch ins Bett gehen irgendwann. Also die warten nur noch auf so einen, bis die letzte Sendung zu Ende ist. Wie ich damals, ich bin immer nach Spongebob ins Bett gegangen, wenn der Sender aufgehört hat zu senden. Und dann bin ich immer ins Bett gegangen. Und da hat dann Nickelodeon aufgehört oder Super RTL Togo aufgehört. Und da wurde es dann wieder zum Hitler-Kanal, da kam dann die KZ-Doku direkt nach Spongebob. Als wir zu DogTV oder sowas. Alte Gags aufwärmen! Ey, warum? 30% von euch haben sie noch nicht gehört. Fantastisch. Wir müssen die Leute abholen. Wir haben ganz viele Leute bekommen, die uns Nachrichten gesendet haben. Zum Beispiel hat Anna uns geschrieben, die hat geschrieben, hallo Florian Stephan, ich bin einer der weiblichen aus Italien kommenden Zuhörer, wir haben ja auch gemerkt, dass viele Ausländer unseren Podcast hören, ich bin echt durch das Podcast, ich bin erst durch das Podcast-UFO auf Neo Magazin Royal gestossen. Was? Nicht schlecht. The other way around. Nächstes Fantreffen, also in Bozen, nein, ihr könnt doch einfach alle Städte mit B abklappern, nein, vielen Dank an Anna für diese nette Nachricht, vielen Dank, dass wir auch Hörerinnen aus Bella Italia haben, Stefans eigentlich Heimat, ja, man muss mal sehen, also manchmal ist es ja so. Ich bin zum Viertel Italiener, also mein Opa ist Italiener, kommt aus Florenz, eine
kleine Stadt neben Florenz.
Und ja, ich bin oft da gewesen, spreche Italienisch fliessend, deswegen an meine lieben Freunde, ciao! Alles klar. Ja, freut uns natürlich sehr, wenn ihr da draußen aus Bozen kommt, dann trefft doch mal Anna. Ihr scheint nett zu sein. Warst du schon mal in Italien, warst dein Lieblingsland, außer Deutschland, was das Reisen angeht? Ach, das ist schwer zu sagen, weil ich war als Kind sehr viel im Urlaub. Mit meinem Vater, meinem Onkel sind wir durch die halbe Welt gereist und haben uns alles angeschaut. Dann lange nichts und dann jetzt halt nochmal letztens New York. Das war alles. Dazwischen kam dann lange nichts. Wir sind auch früher jedes Jahr nach Italien gefahren. Es war auch immer super, da irgendwie immer am Strand rumzuliegen und Sachen zu machen. Du du bist ein Strandtyp, ne? Ich bin eigentlich gar kein Strandtyp. Direkt das Shirt wird weggezogen, als die Ländergrenze nach Italien überschreiten. Die Zehen graben sich in den heißen Sand und kommen da so schnell nicht mehr raus, sag ich mal. Wegen, weil du fett warst, muss man sagen. Richtig, ich hab mich dann immer, da gab es dann die Spielhüllen, wo ich bis heute nicht genau weiß, ob Spielhalle oder Hölle, aber ich habe immer Spielhölle gesagt, vielleicht als Kind ist das irgendwo in der Übersetzung verloren gegangen, wo man dann an so ganz vielen Arcade-Maschinen dann da irgendwie so Metal Slug oder dann irgendwie Monkey Ball Island spielen kann. Oder Air Hockey, Air Hockey ist super. Eher Hockey auch, aber eher so wie diese klassischen Spielautomaten und das war wirklich das absolute Highlight. Und da hat sich dann in meiner Jugend dann genauso entwickelt, wo man dann langsam einfach irgendwann alle diese
Spiele auf seinem Gameboy hatte und
sich gefragt hat, ja, warum muss ich denn da jetzt noch
50 Cent einwerfen, um spielen zu können, bis ich
einmal tot bin. Aber es ist natürlich
schon eine andere Romantik und die sind jetzt wahrscheinlich alle weg
mittlerweile, weil jedes Kind halt irgendwie
Nintendo DS oder sowas hat. Weiß ich nicht, aber ich habe mich
gerade gefragt, warum gibt es Airhockey nicht
im, weil das ist ja so ein bisschen eine
Adaption von Eishockey,
aber warum gibt es das nicht in echt,
also warum gibt es nicht Eishockey
Vielen Dank. Ich habe mich gerade gefragt, warum gibt es Airhockey nicht im ... Weil das ist ja so ein bisschen eine Adaption von Eishockey. Aber warum gibt es das nicht in echt ... Also warum gibt es nicht Eishockey, aber mit diesen kleinen Blasdingern, diesen Punkten, wo Luft rauskommt ... Ach so, aber da läuft man da drauf, oder was? Aber dass Leute schweben. Weil diese Scheibe, die da rumsaust, die schwebt ja auch. Mit Karacho saust die da rum, aber die schwebt, weil da so viel Luft rauskommt. Wie geil wäre das denn bitte, wenn das, das wäre einfach so wie Quidditch. Aber schwebt die wirklich oder hat die nur dann reduziert in der Reibung oder schwebt die wirklich in der Luft? Ja, aber mikroskopisch klein hebt die nur ab. Mit einem mikroskopisch kleinen Aufstand. Braust die durch die Luft. So ein Airhockey hat tatsächlich beim Zivildienst mit Kindern gemacht und bei einer Tagesstätte haben die sich auch so ein Airhockey-Ding gekauft. Da hatten Kinder ein Auge verloren, tatsächlich. Ja, richtig. Und das wurde antransportiert in so einer grossen Box. Das Kind. In einem grossen Karton, ja, ja. Und dann stand da wirklich drauf, also oft steht ja auch so Kartons drauf, zerbrechlich oder Achtung, zerbrechlich oder Achtung, Airhockey, Spar, Spar, Spar. Leute, ohne Scheiß, es ist wirklich fucking zerbrechlich, aber da stand wirklich, also das war knallrot das Paket und da stand wirklich, lo, wo, wo, wo, wo, bevor ihr dieses Paket anfasst, liess erst mal, der Inhalt ist wirklich zerbrechlich, also no bullshit hier, das ist wirklich fucking zerbrechlich, weil da halt diese Glasscheibe drin war, die halt dann das Zentrum von diesem ganzen Ding gemacht hat und die ist halt mega zerbrechlich und auch wenn da schon die Kanten wegbrechen, hast du halt verloren. Weil das dann nicht mehr reinsetzt und dann ist das nicht mehr luftdicht oder irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung. Aber auf jeden Fall stand da wirklich tausendmal drauf, Leute, ganz im Ernst, lasst es Profis machen, fasst es gar nicht erst an oder kauft es erst nicht, aber jetzt lass mich in Ruhe. Und dann habe ich das da irgendwie mit drei Kindern, die irgendwie gerade irgendwie Nutella an den Händen hatten, da muss ich das dann irgendwie in den zweiten Stock hochschleppen, mit den drei dicken Kindern. Die Glitch-Schleim an den Händen hatten. Ja genau, wo es dann heißt so, ey, ich brauche drei starke Kinder und die Betreuerin zeigt auf die drei fetten Kinder und gibt sie, dann denkst du dir, die sind nicht stark, wir haben nur schwere Knochen. Ja, aber das ist schon so, dass man bei fetten Menschen auch davon ausgeht, dass sie stärker sind, schon ein bisschen.
Ja, weil da, wo die sonst die Muskeln sind, ist ja jetzt halt auch ein paar Masse. Das ist, glaube ich, das einzige, was Menschen denken. Die sehen da, das könnte Bizeps sein, könnte massive Fett sein, die können ja auch stark sein unter ihrem Fettmantel. Du siehst ja solchen Fettkindern auch im Gesicht an, dass sie irgendwie da wirklich jetzt auch zwischen ihren Fettfalten nichts aus Butter haben. Mir ist aufgefallen, man sieht oft am T-Shirt an, wie fett jemand ist.
Ja.
Ich würde sogar sagen, dass Leute, die mit einem Metallica-Shirt rumlaufen oder mit einem Rocket Beans-Shirt rumlaufen, mit einem Verwaschenen, also man kann am Grad der Verwaschung und am Grad der Band erkennen, wie fett jemand ist. Ich glaube, fette Leute neigen eher zum Batman-Shirt als dünne Menschen. Ja, das stimmt. Oder sehr, sehr dünne Menschen. Man erkennt es oft nicht als Batman-Shirt, weil es dann so ein bisschen verzerrt ist. Genau. Passt eigentlich schon. Und halt kurze Hosen, so das Trademark. Kurze und Hemden, Hawaii-Hemden glaube ich auch manchmal. Ich habe mich gefragt eben, ich kann mich erinnern, als mein Fisch kam, stand auf dem Paket Lebendtier-Transport und es war halt aber nur so eine Box, so eine Sty Styroporbox. Und mein Nachbar wusste ja nicht, als er es angenommen hatte, was
für ein Wesen da drin ist. Das heißt,
er stand den ganzen Tag, stellte mir vor,
er satt am Schreibtisch, hat irgendwie was für die Uni gemacht,
aber daneben, in seinem
Blickfeld stand halt dieses kleine Paket, wo
Lebendtier-Transport draufsteht.
Was hat er gedacht, was da drin ist?
Ob er mal so rangehört hat,
oder so versucht hat zu kommunizieren, so Videos abgespielt hat, so so eine Python. Nee, Belgien noch? Ist Belgien nicht dieses Land, wo viele drüber lachen, weil es für nichts steht? Ist das der Gag oder habe ich den Gag immer falsch verstanden? Nee, das ist Ruanda. Nee, Belgien ist Kinderschänder. Ruanda steht für viel. Hä, wofür denn? Hotel oder was? Gute Hotels. Für Vielfältigkeit. Klar, Ruanda steht für mich. Also steht für mich zum einen für diese tolle Baumart, diese mit den runden Stämmen. Dann ganz toll das Essen. Die Nationalküche Ruandas ist für mich eine der vielfältigsten. Stimmt, das mit den Beilagen und dem Hauptgang, das kommt aus Ruanda. Für mich Wahnsinn. Dann diese, es ist ja auch eine der einzigen Länder, wo man mit Messer und Gabel ist. Stimmt, vor allem, ich glaube, Ruanda ist auch eines der wenigen Länder, die sowohl eine Flora als auch eine Fauna haben. Als auch eine Fauna haben. Das ist ja ganz geil. Das lernt man sofort im Adcon-Unterricht. Ja, das Recht, Ruanda war ein dummes Beispiel. Aber Hotels, gute Hotels natürlich auch in Ruanda. Gute Hotels, also viele Hotels auch. Also Hilton, Marriott, gibt es da zuhauf. Also du hast gerade gesagt, Ruanda assoziierst du mit Krieg. Finde ich sehr rassistisch und unpassend. Nee, da ist er gerade... Ja, aber gibt es denn ein Land, das man nicht mit Krieg assoziiert? Also gibt es wirklich ein Land, das noch nie im Krieg war? Nee, aber ich assoziiere... Ich glaube, es sind zwei Länder, die noch nie... Island. Island assoziiere ich mit keinem Krieg. Also Island ist für mich... Die können doch einfach sagen, nö. Weil niemand greift Island an, weil niemand will Island. Island hat coole Lagunen, okay, aber das ist kein Grund dafür anzugreifen. Hallo und Lagune, nennen wir Lagunen? Lagunen, das ist die Blue Lagun. Ich war kurz davor, meinen Urlaub in Island zu verbringen, aber es ist halt ein bisschen aufwendig, wenn man da halt lange hinfliegt und nicht direkt hinfliegen kann. Glaubst du, es ist ein Unterschied für so ein Lebensgefühl? Also wir leben ja in Deutschland, zu Info, eines der wichtigsten Länder der Welt. Und ich glaube, das wirkt sich schon auf die Bevölkerung aus, wenn man denkt, okay, unser Land ist nicht scheißegal. Weil wenn du so in Island wohnst, du denkst, Krieg mit Island wird nicht stattfinden. Aber die Chance, Nationalheld zu werden, ist relativ gross. Aber da passiert ja nichts. Ja, aber du bist trotzdem Nationalheld. Wohingegen, wenn du in Deutschland Nationalheld wirst, ist es zwar schon per se eine coole Leistung, aber du gehörst einem so grossen westlichen Komplex an, dass du weisst, es zählt nicht so viel. Ich glaube, je mehr in einem Land passiert, desto mehr hast du auch überdurchschnittlich proportional die Chance, Held zu werden. Also da gibt es Fussball-EMs, wir sind sportlich sehr erfolgreich, wir haben Krieg, wir haben gute Wissenschaftler, Physiker haben wir ohne Ende, wir haben Philosophen, wir haben Dichter, wir haben Musiker ohne Ende. Du kannst dir so viele Sachen aussuchen, wo du Held werden kannst, wohingegen Island, da gab es diesen einen coolen Politiker und that's it. Den du interviewt hast. Aber das war es halt auch einfach, mehr nicht. Und ich glaube in Deutschland, aber es ist ja wirklich so, wenn du denkst. Aber das lacht viel über Island aus, der coolste Typ von denen hat sich von dir interviewen lassen. Das lacht viel über das Land aus. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, wenn du deutsche Nachrichten liest, denkst du dir, okay, das ist wichtig. Serious Business, oh scheiße, wir müssen wählen, oh fuck, wir müssen jetzt wirklich gucken, dass der Typ, dass die AfD nicht zu krass wird, weil sonst, wenn die AfD halt auf der Rechts ist, dann haben wir halt den Weltkrieg vielleicht, schlimmsten Fall. Leute, wir müssen nicht aufpassen. Aber in Island liest man doch die Nachricht so, ja so what. Aber da frage ich mich auch, lesen die primär ihre eigenen Landesnachrichten oder sagen auch die, ja, mal gucken, was so in Dänemark los ist, so die nächstgrosten? Weiss ich gar nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich finde es nur so spannend, als sie bei der EM ja relativ gut waren, wurden die ja alle zu Nationalhelden instant, die ganzen Spieler, obwohl die nicht mal wirklich weit gekommen sind.
Und dann war es ja auch so interessant, dass fast die Hälfte der ganzen Bevölkerung Islands nach Frankreich gereist sind, um da die zu sehen. Wo ich mir denke, da war dann im Stadionblock auch nur der Gästeblock oder so, wo halt Island dann war, die isländischen Fans, waren dann halt quasi halb gefüllt mit dem ganzen Land. Ja, vor allem Island steht komplett lahm. Ich stelle mir so eine Supermarktkasse vor, wo alle so warten und so, hallo, wo ist der Kassierer? Die kennen sich ja auch alle. Also du kennst ja, ich würde mal sagen, wenn du in einer Stadt lebst von so 50.000 Menschen, hast du viele schon mal gesehen im Laufe deines 20 Jahre alten Lebens. Ich glaube, wenn du da in Island so durch bist, wenn du da einmal, wenn du 80 Jahre alt bist, kennst du sehr viele Menschen. Das ist schon krass. Ja, das stimmt, Jan. Wenn man so ein ganzes Land kennt. Ich glaube, Island ist wie das Pondor zu einem Dorf. Die wollen alle raus irgendwann, die wollen halt in die grösseren Städte, in die grösseren Länder. Man will weg vom Dorf, der Trend geht weg vom Dorf. Island stirbt langsam aus. Das ist meine These. Alles klar, wir haben eine weitere Nachricht bekommen, und zwar von der Ruth, die uns schreibt, war eine weitere Vertreterin des weiblichen Geschlechts, schreibt uns. Hallo lieber Stefan und lieber Florentin, die Ruth hier, Langzeithörerin, erstmalige Fan-Mail-Verfasserin, also ever. Ihr seid also sozusagen Teil eines Experiments und wir können gemeinsam begründen, ob es sich als gelungen oder eher als meh herausstellt. Schon lustig. Ich wollte euch schon eine Weile lang schreiben und nach eurem letzten Podcast finde ich mein Timing jetzt etwas fast etwas doof, da ihr eure weiblichen Hörer ja darum gebeten habt, doch auch mal einen Pieps von sich zu geben. Aber da ihr ebenfalls von eurer internationalen Community geredet habt, dachte ich, es ist Zeit, doch mal Hallo zu sagen. Ich schreibe euch nämlich aus Dänemark. Canberra, Australien, wo ich seit neun Jahren lebe. Meine Familie zog nach Canberra oder Canberra, als ich 16 war nach sechs Jahren. Oder Dresden.
Nach sechs Jahren gingen meine Eltern zurück nach Berlin, ich zog für drei Jahre nach Schottland und bin jetzt seit 2013 wieder hier. Der Grund, warum ich euch keine mehr schreiben wollte, ist vielleicht ein wenig kitschig. Manchmal vermisse ich Deutschland schon, Kleinigkeiten wie den Geruch deutscher Bäckereien, Bahnhöfe nicht der Geruch oder generell der tolle Bahnverkehr, die Supermärkte, die anderen Frühstückskultur, Bacon und Eggs geht klar, aber manchmal hat man schon Lust auf... So, das gingen noch zehn Seiten so weiter. Wir spielen mal zum Ende. Ey, du darfst... Also sie freut sich, dass wir aus dem deutschen Alltag erzählen. Das stimmt, das hat mich auch so, das finde ich auch, da kann sie sich immer gerne wiedererkennen. Ich würde euch gerne ein Foto von Sydney, aber bis dahin erst mal ganz viele Grüße auf dem Facebook-Wiege. Macht's gut! Ciao! Macht's gut, viele Grüße an Ruthie aus Australia, auch ein sehr friedliebendes Volk, glaube ich. Aussies! Ne, stimmt gar nicht, haben auch einen zweiten Verkrieg, haben die auch richtig Radau gemacht, aber... Bin ich mir nicht sicher. Doch, doch, die hatten so in Alliierten. Die hatten so Hüte auf. Die Australian Devils. Ach, diese Ranger-Hüte. Die sind auf Kängurus angeritten. Reihenweise erschossen. Dumme Idee, Leute. Die hätten einfach, glaube ich, den Krieg beenden können, wenn die alle die ganze Tierwelt genommen hätten und einfach mit so einem grossen Sack ausgesetzt hätten. In Deutschland wäre Deutschland... Die Austral lassen wir sie allein. Wir sagen nicht, wie man Kängurus zähmt. Diese ganzen Spinnen und der ganze Scheiss. Das ist gar nicht so doof eigentlich. Schon lustig. Es wird oft darüber Gags gemacht, dass Australien einen sofort killt, aber es ist immer lustig. Wenn du im Outback bist, hast du verloren. Das ist schon lustig. Outback bedeutet, Australien wird ja nur an den äusseren Rändern angeht und in der Mitte ist einfach wie so ein schwarzes Loch, wo noch niemand sich mal durchgetraut hat und in der Mitte ist irgendwie dann so ein Portal oder sowas. Genau, da ist ja dieser grosse Ayers Rock und dann mehr ist dann nicht bekannt, glaube ich. Gab es nicht mal die Legende, dass Erdogan ein Stargate hat? Erdogan? Ja. Ich glaube, ja Kim mit dem Unn, oder? Nee, er ist irgend so ein arabisches Feld. Es gibt ja auch wirklich die Theorie von so einem Verschwörungstheoretiker, dass die Nazis mit Nikola Tesla zum Pluto geflogen sind und da dann Gestein gesammelt haben und die in fünf Stunden da waren. Aha. Was ich ganz spannend Das ist sehr spannend, ja. Weil wir haben das gemacht mit der Technik. Weil Nikola Tesla vierzehn Jahre vor der Machtbereifung gestorben ist, aber das war jetzt weniger das Problem. Aber in fünf Stunden zum Pluto. Das ist schnell. Das ist eine ganze Menge. Das ist schnell. Und dann auch mit Sitzreservierungen und WLAN. Ja, das ist Respekt. Wahnsinn. Geil. Aber gut, die Nazis. Warum haben sie kein Foto gemacht, das ist meine Frage an der Stelle. Warum haben sie nicht gesagt so, hey hey Leute, übrigens, so ein Selfie von Pluto. Ihr habt uns ja kaputtgebombt, dann sind die ganzen Fotos kaputt gegangen, so, habt ihr jetzt davon. Pluto ist ja sehr klein, ne, ich glaube, da konnte man auch gar nicht drauf stehen, weil sonst der Planet ist. Der ist einfach nur sehr klein, alle haben sich so eine Hand genommen, so lustige Fotos, wie beim schiefen Tun von Pisa. Genau, aber halt echt. Oder irgendwann wird das passieren. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wer ist der erste...
Was ist, dass ein Planet gefunden wird, der so klein ist?
Was ist die erste... genommen, so lustige Fotos, wie beim Schiefenturm von Pisa. Genau, aber halt echt. Oder irgendwann wird das passieren.
Was, dass ein Planet gefunden wird, der so klein ist?
Was ist die erste,
nein, das sind dann keine Planeten mehr,
aber wer war der erste, der
dieses Foto gemacht hat vom Schiefenturm
von Pisa, dieses, oh, ich halte ihn
auf, sonst gibt er um ohne mich,
wer hat dieses Foto gemacht? Ich wäre gerne der erste,
der irgendwie... Ach, das bedeutet das? Ich dachte, man schiebt
ihn um. Man ist von der anderen Seite und drückt ihn um. Nee, nee. Du bist zerstörerisch am Start. Leute wollen das aufhalten, die halten den fest so. Von der anderen Seite. Ich hab das, das ist jetzt auch der Mandela-Effekt, ich hab mein ganzes Leben lang. Ja, Mandela-Effekt, Leute, ich sag's euch. Ich dachte, dass man den so umdrückt. Ach, jetzt raff ich's erst. Die wollen den nicht zerstören, die wollen den heilen. Du bist das Gegenteil von einem guten Menschen.
Aber ich würde gerne der Erste sein, der so Space-Tourismus betreibt, zum Pluto reist und dann den so zwischen seine Finger nimmt und so tut, das wäre wahnsinnig klein. Aber das ist eigentlich jemals ein Astronaut gemacht, wenn du auf den Mond stießt, kannst du dir bestimmt auch die Erde so in den Fingerkneifzangen nehmen, oder? Es war ja so ein Spruch von einem, der zum ersten Mal zum Mond gereist ist, ins Weltall, irgendwie so ein Apollo-Astronaut, der hat seinen Daumen vor die Erde gehalten, hat dann gesagt, Wahnsinn, alles, was ich weiss und jemals wusste und jemals wissen werde, passiert auf diesem Planeten, der gerade kleiner ist als mein Daumen-Fingernagel. Und das ist ein cooler Gedanke. Und damit zunächst Nachricht. Ob er das wirklich gesagt hat, oder? Ich weiss es nicht. Ich traue dem, ich traue Astronauten. Ich traue es mir nicht. Ich glaube, Astronauten sind die grössten Lügner der Welt, weil kann ja niemand nachweisen. Du kannst sagen, auf dem Mond haben wir das und das gemacht und da habe ich das und das gesagt und da hatten wir dir nur den tollen Gedanken. Warum hat er nicht auf dem Mond gepinkelt? Ich glaube, das zerreißt sich innerlich komplett, oder? Da ist ja Vakuum da oben. Oder? Nee.
Aber das denke ich mal.
Nee, sorry, nur weil kein Sauerstoff ist, ist nicht automatisch Vakuum. Ah, die Physiker, fuck you einfach. Stopp, stopp. Aber wir sind ja keine Freunde vom Pipi-Kaka-Humor, wir sind ja wirklich da, wir sind ja Erwachsener. Aber ganz kurz mal eben wirklich eine Frage, die mich wirklich beschäftigt. Wenn man O-Saft auskippt, geht das ja manchmal nicht ganz flüssig, weil da ja auch Luft nachkommen muss. Also du kannst es ja nur, du würdest einen Unterdruck erzeugen in der Flasche, wenn da halt nur O-Saft rauskommt. Da muss ja immer ein bisschen Luft nachkommen, deswegen schwappt das ja so. Das heißt, du kannst ja auch, na gut, wenn du jetzt eine Flasche umkippst, kommt da halt nicht sofort Wasser raus, weil das ja erstmal muss auch Luft nachfließen. Es gluckert dann so, ja. Richtig.
Aber wenn man uriniert, kommt ja
auch Wasser raus die ganze Zeit und es
kommt keine Luft nach in die Blase,
wo ich mir denke, man müsste jetzt ein Unterdruck in der Blase
entstehen. Das ist ja dehnbar.
Ja, klar. Flaschen sind ja auch dehnbar.
Nee, das ist ja wie ein Luftballon. Wenn du Luftballon
dann ein Loch reinmachst, dann kommt ja auch
Wasser raus, ohne dass Luft nachkommen muss,
weil das Fassungsvermögen
des Luftballons kleiner wird, weil der sich
nachgibt. Also
Also duachst, dann kommt ja auch Wasser raus, ohne dass Luft nachkommen muss, weil das Fassungsvermögen des Luftballons kleiner wird, weil der sich nachgibt. Also du meinst, dass die Blase wird langsam kleiner? Ja, würde ich schon sagen. Aber dann ist sie ja irgendwann nicht mehr existent, weil irgendwann ist sie ja komplett leer. Na gut. Irgendwann ist sie leer, aber ich glaube sogar, dass sie nie ganz leer ist. Ich glaube, da bleibt immer was zurück. Ich denke mir, ich muss mich mal einatmen ganz doll, wenn ich uriniere, damit dann Luft nachkommt in die Blase.
Was ich mir immer denke, weil das mit der Luft ist nämlich kein dummer Gedanke.
Wie du das sagst.
Ja, das ist ganz normal gesagt. Wenn ich nur dumme, dumme Sachen sage, das war nämlich jetzt kein dummer, aber auch beleidigend.
Ich denke nämlich immer bei Operationen, wenn die so deine Bauchdecke aufmachen und da irgendwie so einmal schön durchrühren, um wieder zuzumachen und dann bist du geheilt. Wenn die dann das wieder zunähen, dann müssen die ja wahrscheinlich schon aufpassen, dass da keine Luftpolster entstehen. Wenn das einfach wie so ein Reisekoffer so zuziehst und dann so ein Luftkissen unter der Haut ist, das geht ja nicht mehr raus. Weil die Haut ist ja schon luftdicht, oder? Nee, das glaube ich nicht. Nee, nee, wir atmen ja auch ein bisschen durch die Haut, so einen ganz kleinen Prozentteil. Ja, aber das geht ja nur in One Way, das ist ja Einwanderstrasse. Ich weise es nicht mehr. Du kannst ja nicht Luft, wo soll das denn nicht mehr? Ich glaube, wenn du Luft in den Adern, im Blut hast, hast du einfach verloren. Ja, in den Adern hast du sofort verloren. Aber du bist ja einfach tot. Deswegen machst du ja immer diese Tropf-, diese Schnipsgeste, wenn du nicht mehr spritzt. Ja, aber das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, wenn so eine Ärztin oder so eine Krankenschwester, dass du dann, wenn die nur so ein kleines Luftpolster in Blut ballert, dann hast du einfach, dann bist du tot. Blut, dann hast du es ja irgendwann im Herzen. Und da darf Blut nicht sein, weil da musst du einen konstituellen Druck haben. Und das Herz rastet halt komplett aus. Alter, das ist so unangenehm. Aber ich denke mir, was passiert, weil ist denn Weil ist denn zwischen den Organen, also zwischen Leber und Lunge, was als nächstes ist, ist da Luft? Ich verstehe die Frage, ich verstehe auch, wo diese Unwissenheit herkommt. Ich habe das nämlich mit Wasser. Diese Prozentzahl, dass wir zu acht Prozent aus Wasser bestehen, die akzeptiere ich auch nicht als die Wahrheit. Ja, das ist ja die Frage, was ist dann Wasser? Ja, was ist Wasser? Also ich glaube, damit ist halt Wassermoleküle gemeint.
Also jetzt nicht Wasser, dass du dich wie so ein Schwamm ausdrückst und dann kommt da echtes Wasser raus, sondern eine Gurke besteht ja auch zu grössten Teilen aus Wasser, aber die ist ja auch fest und die kannst du jetzt auch nicht auswringen wie so ein Schwamm. Eine Qualle kannst du auch quasi auswringen. Ne, eine Qualle besteht zu 80 Prozent aus Plastiktüte und zu 20% aus Wasser.
Dankeschön und damit zum nächsten.
Wir warten auf den ersten guten One-Liner und dann geht es los mit der nächsten Nachricht.
Wer hat noch geschrieben? Mir hat auch jemand geschrieben, aber auf Snapchat.
Also mir hat eine Frau geschrieben, ein junges Mädchen, die wollte wohl ihren Freund anschreiben bei Snapchat und hat dann so eine Nachricht geschrieben und hat dann wohl mir geschrieben aus Versehen und hat dann gesagt, ja gut, das war jetzt nicht für dich, aber ihr habt ja eher ausgeschrieben, dass wenn Frauen was euch schreiben, dann lese ich das vor. Und dann hat sie halt irgendwas geschrieben, das weiß ich halt nicht mehr, weil es auf Snapchat immer schnell verschwindet, deswegen kann ich es nicht mehr wiedergeben, leider. Sorry! Hast du diese Nachricht gelesen mit dem Typen und seiner Freundin? Ja, habe ich gelesen, aber verdreht. Wollen wir da drauf eingehen? Ja. Schon, ne? Okay, ich frage mal, ob ich sie finde, weil das hat mich so fertig gemacht, ey, das hat mich richtig fertig gemacht für einen Moment. Also, wir haben Nachricht gelesen. Holy moly, also ich kann ja mal Teile daraus vorlesen.
Hoffentlich ist es okay, aber ich glaube schon.
Ich glaube schon, wir werden den Namen nicht voll vorlesen.
Und ansonsten, ich habe leider hier ein schlechtes Internet.
Er ist immer, schlechtes Internet ist immer die Geissel der Unterhaltung.
So müssen sich Römer gefühlt haben.
Die haben bestimmt jahrelang auf so eine einzelne E-Mail gewartet.
Ja, aber dann haben sie so tolle Sachen gemacht, wie zum Beispiel. Gerade Straßen, ja! Städte verbrannt, wollte ich jetzt sagen, und Gag machen, okay. Ja, ist ja potenziell erlaubt erst mal. Ich glaube, Nero ist ein Produkt keines Internets. Was, angenommen, du würdest in die Vergangenheit reisen, würdest du, was ist das Erste, was du versuchen würdest, auch wenn du es nicht schaffen würdest, nachzubauen?
Also so Internet würdest du ja nicht vermissen.
Erstens könntest du es nicht nachbauen und zweitens interessiert dich auch nicht, was Kaiser Aurelius schreibt.
Ich würde erst mal versuchen, irgendwas nachzubauen, was mich in die Position bringt, dass mich alle als Genie akzeptieren.
Gut, da würde mir per se schon eine Taschenlampe reichen.
Ja, aber das ist nicht so leicht.
Fluggerät. Ich glaube, ich würde sterben bei dem Versuch, ein Fluggerät zu bauen. Nun, nur die Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regeln der Regelnen. Da musst du halt erst mal zu dem Mönch oder zu dem Gelehrten hingehen, der halt grob Mathe checkt, aber du verstehst ja auch dessen Zahlen. Du könntest dir nicht mehr Pi erklären. Du könntest Pi entdecken. Doch, du könntest erklären, hier, Kreiszahl, wie das funktioniert. Ja, und Leglos. Fläche. So, Herr, wie war Ihr Name? Hä? Will. Florentinus. Gebreiter Will. Ach, ich bin komplett raus. Ey, mit den Scheissbegriffen. Nee, pass mal auf hier. Fläche von einem Kreis. Schwer auszurechnen. Ja, wie tun Sie das denn? Machen wir einfach. Ist Pi mal Radius Quadrat. Bitte? Pi mal Radius Quadrat. Bitte, Quadrat verstehe ich ja noch. Ja, nee, tust du nicht, weil Kalkulus ja später erfunden wurde. Aber ich erkläre es dir, es ist ganz einfach Pi mal Radius mal Radius. Easy. Wir sind ein Genie. Guck mal, hier, ich lege da viele Reiskörner rein, dann können Sie sehen, dass es stimmt. So, und dann hast du schon mal gewonnen und dann sagst du, oh, was weißt du denn noch, dann haust du mal die Mittelnachtsformel raus. Du würdest nicht mal eine Audienz bei so einem Typen bekommen. Du würdest nicht mal zu dem hinkommen und dem das erklären können, weil du an Leuten vorbei musst, die dumm sind. Aber zu einem Kloster kann man doch gehen, oder? Was willst du im Kloster? Ja, da sind ja Gelehrte, die können zumindest mal lesen oder die Mönche halt. Scheiss Mönche, ey, Mann. Für einen Kloster? Also jetzt, dass ich nicht auf dem Königshof gelassen werde, ist klar, aber zu einem Kloster. Ich meine, du musst erst mal überleben, bis du da hinkommst, ist wahrscheinlich schon schwer genug und nicht irgendwie die schwarze Seuche, die da einfangen, die da irgendwie durch die Länder zieht und jenen mitnimmt. Du meinst schwarze Menschen? Ja, aber die hat man damals noch nicht so genannt. Die schwarze Zeug hast du, ja. Möchtest du die nächste Nachricht vorlesen? Das ist mir komplett egal jetzt mittlerweile. Eine weitere Nachricht, die wir bekommen haben, von Caro Dissel. Caro schreibt, hallo ihr zwei, auf euren Wunsch hin melde ich mich als weibliche Zuhörerin, die dann auch noch Ausländerin ist. Ich bin Luxemburgerin und höre den Podcast seit einigen Monaten immer im Auto auf dem Weg zur Arbeit. Durch euren Aufruf in Folge 75 habe ich endlich meinen Mut zusammengefasst, euch zu schreiben. Warum braucht ihr Mut? Schreibt uns einfach, wir freuen uns über jede Nachricht. Nein, was ich euch nämlich schon länger erklären wollte, ist die Bedeutung des Sprichworts Einem geschenkten Gaul schaut man nicht ins Maul. Und dann erklärt sie, dass es an den Zähnen liegt, die oft das Alter verraten haben.
Vielleicht hätten Jeffs Zähne etwas über sein Alter verraten können, oder ist es noch zu früh für solche Kommentare?
Auf jeden Fall weiter so und keep it.
Komm mal her.
Ist okay.
Dankeschön.
Auf jeden Fall weiter so und keep it das Podcast.
Du darfst auch weinen.
Du, ich trauere für mich, okay? Kann ich selber unterscheiden, wie ich trauern will? Nee, ist okay. Nimm dir, was du brauchst. Kann ich deinen Laptop haben? Nee, der hilft gerade eh nicht. Ich habe leider keinen Riss. Aber das war Caro. Vielen Dank, Caro. Luxemburgerin. Und das ist auch seltsam, weil das stand gar nicht in unseren Statistiken. Ganz seltsam. Wir kriegen ja oft Nachrichten von euch. Wir lesen alle tatsächlich, auch wenn wir nicht immer antworten können, aber manchmal kriegen wir echt Nachrichten, wo man auch wirklich merkt, okay, das ist hier nicht nur alberner Scheiss, sondern manchmal wird es halt auch ernst. Und wir haben eine Nachricht bekommen von Kevin. Manchmal bekommt man auch Nachrichten, oft kriegen wir Nachrichten, dass Leute an Depressionen leiden. Ja, also wir haben schon bekommen, also jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, dass Leute an Depressionen leiden und irgendwie durch uns sich ein bisschen aufmuntern lassen und so, was immer mega geil ist zu hören. Da sind wir wahrscheinlich jetzt auch nicht die beste Hilfe dafür, sondern besorgt euch professionelle Hilfe. Ich finde das Tolle daran, aber dass man macht Unterhaltung ja auch immer ein bisschen für sich, aber das sowas zu hören, dann ist das auch schon schön. So, aber manchmal passieren halt auch leider Dinge und ich muss sagen, als ich das gelesen habe, war ich echt fertig.
Also es hat mich richtig erwischt, das ist vielleicht irgendwie auch ein Thema, je nachdem für jeden persönlich unterschiedlich hart.
Aber ey, meine fucking Herren, da merkt man echt, man will ja nur helfen und Leute glücklich machen, aber manchmal.
Also Kevin schreibt, begrüsst uns und dann schreibt er, in der Folge 39 Hotel Monopol Hamburg, Minute 1155, redet über Partys und eine hypothetische, coole Hannah. Und Florentin beleidigt sie im Endeffekt. Nun, da meine Freundin zufälligerweise Hannah heißt, fand ich den Ausschnitt sehr amüsant und habe das Ende davon an sie geteilt. Am nächsten Tag habe ich erfahren, dass sie überall auf sämtlichen Social-Media-Seiten mich entfreundet und gelöscht hat, sogar jeden meiner Kommentare. Jedes Zeichen unserer Beziehung wurde ausradiert. Sie hat mich auf meine schriftliche Nachfrage hin verlassen, weil ich sie öffentlich beleidigt hatte, etwas, was mir nicht ferner liegen würde. Ich dachte wirklich, sie würde es witzig finden, ihren Namen in einem Podcast-Rant zu hören. Humor und Ironie war immer ein Teil unserer Beziehung und dass sie wegen eines Ausschnitts des Podcast-Ufos so heftig reagierte und mich nun hasst, überrascht mich doch sehr. Wie lange waren Sie zusammen? Steht hier nicht. Ihr seid Gagautoren und Humor ist euer Beruf. Ich habe nur erlebt, dass man durch Humor und eine witzig gemeinte Post die Liebe seines Lebens verlieren kann. Oh Gott. Momentan versuche ich meine Depressionen zu überwinden und höre seit Tagen dennoch weiter das Podcast-Uwe in der Hoffnung auf Besserung. Alter, Kevin. Fuck, Mann. Können wir uns wieder zusammenbringen, indem wir jetzt Hanna loben oder so? Das Problem ist leider, dass wir nicht genug wissen darüber, da ist es wirklich einschätzen zu können. Ja. Aber auf der anderen Seite glaube ich einfach, hat sie gedacht, dass du sie, dass du im Podcast sprichst? Ich glaube, dass sie dachte, dass er sie öffentlich beleidigt hätte, weil er hat es auch auf eine semiöffentliche Art gepostet. Er hat es auf Snapchat gepostet, auf der ihr aber nur sie folgt. Das heißt, er hat es an sie geschickt, ist er aber potenziell öffentlich. Aber natürlich, wenn es privater Typ ist, wird ihm nicht einfach so Leute folgen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es falsch verstanden hat und dachte, er würde es jetzt mit allen seinen Freunden teilen. Ja, oder sie dachte sogar, dass wir quasi wirklich über sie als Hanna sprechen und er das quasi in dem Podcast, den er hört, eingereicht hat oder so, als Idee oder sowas, so ein Scherz, den sie zu weit fand oder so. Also es sind zu viele Fragen, also es ist schon heftig. Ja, das kann schon sein. Sorry. Ich glaube, Sie haben da so kurz drüber geredet. Ja klar, sorry, aber gut, ist natürlich nicht unsere Schuld. Aber ey, sowas könnte mir ohne weiteres auch sofort passieren. Ja, habe ich aber fast geschafft. Ich mit meinen Scherzen. Ja, das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber das ist schon echt hart und es tut mir auch auch wirklich mega leid, wenn du schreibst, Liebe deines Lebens, wegen so einem Scheiß. Klar, man kann jetzt natürlich auch sagen, wenn es an sowas dann am Ende scheitert, irgendwie dann ist es dann die Liebe des Lebens. Ja gut, von seiner Seite vielleicht, weiß ich nicht. Ist jemand, der jemanden wegen des Podcast-Ubos verlässt, nicht einfach ein furchtbarer Mensch? Ich weiß nicht, wie sie halt diese Geste aufgefasst hat, dass wenn sie dachte, er macht sich jetzt wirklich öffentlich über sie lustig und so, klar, auch da kann man jemandem verzeihen, aber wenn das wirklich für sie ein Vertrauensbruch war, ich kann es überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen, gar nicht, aber da ist man natürlich humoristisch auch irgendwo, hat man da andere Erwartungen irgendwie, aber ey, alter Kevin, ey, es tut mir echt leid, ey, das ist echt fucking hart, ich weiss nicht, können wir Hannah eine neue Botschaft schreiben? Können wir irgendwie helfen?
Du dummes Stück Scheiße.
Geh mit ihm wieder zusammen.
Was fällt dir eigentlich ein, er wird so freitig zu machen?
Sowas Bescheuertes, wegen dem Podcast jemanden zu verlassen,
auch wenn es öffentlich wäre.
Hey, mein Gott, lacht jetzt mal weg,
du dumme Kackpratze.
Und jede zweite heißt Hannah, also das ist jetzt auch nicht so,
aber, ne,
das ist ein furchtbarer Name überhaupt. Aber es ist wirklich hart, also keine Ahnung, wenn man dann wirklich so aus dem Nichts heraus dann wegen so einem Scheiss verlassen wird, das ist schon hart, wenn man sich eigentlich mit guter Intention, man wollte was Gutes tun, man wollte den Gag machen und dann plötzlich zack, du bist verlassen. Ich kenne das, man will, also man braucht ja gute Gründe, um mit jemandem Schluss zu machen, aber oft hast du einfach das Gefühl, es geht nicht mehr so richtig und dann wartest du auf was. Also tu dir vielleicht den Gefallen und sag, es lag nicht nur daran, sondern es hat auch länger nicht schon mal funktioniert oder irgendwas anderes. Wie gesagt, also keine gut funktionierte Beziehung scheitert. Ich kann nur die Geschichte aus meinem Leben erzählen, eine sehr private Geschichte, bei der ich unbedingt Schluss machen wollte damals, aber mir keine richtigen Gründe eingefallen sind, ich wollte einfach nicht mehr. Und dann habe ich das Mädchen eingeladen zum Eis und gesagt, es geht nicht mehr. Dann habe ich mir halt eine Liste geschrieben mit Gründen, weil ich genau weiß, ich bin so begeisterungsfähig, wenn ich was sehe, will ich es kaufen, wenn ich sehe, wie jemand anders mit einer Schaufel spielt, will ich die Schaufel haben. Also wenn sie mir gleich sagt, ja, aber eigentlich läuft es ja noch, sage ich, ja, okay, dann sind wir wieder zusammen. Genauso bin ich nämlich, weil ich lasse mich labern, aber ich weiß, dass ich dann nicht glücklich werde dadurch. Also habe ich mir so einen Reminder gemacht, Stefan, du wirst nicht mehr glücklich mit ihr, schreib aus folgenden Gründen, helfen die jetzt mit ihr Schluss zu machen. Da habe ich mir halt wirklich eine Liste gemacht, um den Faden nicht zu verlieren, aber die Liste, ich habe gemerkt, wie einfach Dinge nicht gut genug waren, und sie irgendwann meinte, ja, das können wir ja ändern, das können wir ja ändern. Ja gut, sind wir wieder zusammen oder was? Es war auch echt eine seltsame Situation. Und dann habe ich mir einfach irgendwann Gründe ausgedacht, um zu sagen, jetzt ist es vorbei. Und ich glaube, ich hätte auch sie, ich hätte auch Hannah sein können, weil irgendwann sucht man halt nach Gründen dafür. Und das war auch damals eigentlich schon ganz lustig. So rückblickend war es wirklich lustig, sich eine Liste zu machen und irgendwann Dinge anzufangen. Was ist sie auch für eine, Gründe nicht zu akzeptieren? Ich meine, du kannst halt nicht sagen, du Arschloch und dann kann der Beleidigte nicht sagen, nee, ich bin kein Arschloch, ja okay, dann lassen wir es halt. Es geht halt nicht, wenn ich sage, ich mache aus sieben Grundmitte Schluss, kann sie nicht sagen, ja das können wir ja ändern. Und? Wie alt warst du da? Weiß ich nicht, 18, 17, 18. Okay, ja krass, aber tatsächlich habe ich sowas ähnliches auch schon mal gemacht, dass wenn man in manchen Situationen merkt, also es ist ja, manchmal ist ja so Bewusstsein ein seltsames Ding, weil manchmal in manchen Situationen bist du in der Sache tausendprozentig bewusst und in einem anderen Moment gar nicht mehr so. Das ist ja wirklich, das ist ja nichts Konstantes und das ist merkwürdig, weil du denkst dir, ich kann mich schon noch daran erinnern, dass ich damals so dachte, aber ich krieg's nicht mehr, ich komm nicht mehr in diesen Zustand. Das beste Beispiel für die Manipulation von Emotionen ist folgendes, wenn du mit jemandem hin und her schreibst und man sich so langsam kennenlernt und so und dann schreibst du ihr vielleicht, ja hör mal, was machst du eigentlich heute Abend oder wie geht's dir gerade, was machst du gerade und es kommt keine Antwort und es kommt keine Antwort und es kommt keine Antwort und du wartest und du wartest und du fängst an, fuck, was habe ich geschrieben, du willst die Nachrichten löschen, du willst es zurückholen, du willst was cooleres schreiben, was lustiges schreiben und es kommt nichts und es kommt nichts und dann irgendwann schreibt sie, oh sorry, duschen, alles mir geht super, kein Problem und es verfliegt, diese Wute sich
eben in dir angestaut hat, die ist einfach weg, von jetzt auf gleich ist sie weg und das ist doch
krass, du warst dir so bewusst, dass sie dich hasst, dass die Person, du hast das Falsche geschrieben,
du hast es für immer beendet, die Beziehung und dann sagt sie, sie war duschen und alles ist
egal, also dieses Bewusstsein ist krass. In deinem Kopf ist sie schon fremdgegangen und hat dir auch schon gesagt, dass sie fremdgegangen ist und alles ist schon beendet und du denkst dir, mein Gott, eigentlich war es okay. Wäre sie fremdgegangen, hättest du die gleichen Gedanken gehabt. Es ist nicht so, dass in deinem Kopf genau das Schlimme passiert, was im echten Leben dramatischerweise hätte passieren können, aber was nicht passiert ist. Man bereitet sich manchmal auch so präventiv schon darauf vor, ich bereite mich jetzt auf die Nachricht vor, dass sie jeden Moment schreibt, ich mach Schluss und du bist dann gedanklich schon so weit, dass du schon weiterziehst und denkst, ach jetzt kann ich mehr WoW zocken oder so in der Richtung, aber nee, aber das ist tatsächlich, Herr Gast und sowas ähnliches habe ich auch gemacht, dass ich auch mal in so einer halben Beziehung war und dann auch eine Situation gab, wo ich dann wirklich in mein iPhone geschrieben habe, das wird nichts mehr, so merkt ihr bitte diesen Gedanken, Ich weiß, jetzt bin ich im Moment, wo ich technisch nicht Schluss machen kann. Ich sehe es gerade klar. Aber ich habe einen Moment der Klarheit und ich schreibe mir es auf und bitte, und ich habe wirklich geschrieben so, Florentin, bitte bitte vertrau mir, egal wie du dich fühlst, wenn du diese Nachricht liest, bitte, es wird nichts mehr. Glaub mir. Es hilft so sehr. Aber dann liest du die Nachrichten eine Woche später und denkst dir, nee, Alter, du hast geblendet.
Man hat ja Ups und Downs im Leben.
Und es hilft manchmal, wenn du so einen Moment der Klarheit hast, wo du genau weißt, warum es dir manchmal in den Schlag geht und so.
Solche Momente hast du manchmal.
Das hilft wirklich, das aufzuschreiben.
Deswegen Tagebuch halte ich nicht durch.
Ist nicht doof, aber man hält es nicht durch so richtig.
Also ich zumindest bin kein Mensch dafür.
Aber mir hilft es manchmal, Dinge niederzuschreiben. Einfach, wenn man merkt, okay, du hast gerade einen Moment, wo du klar denkst. Ja, absolut. Das ist nicht doof, aber es ist auch im Gegenteil, auch wenn es dir gut geht oder wenn du irgendwie glückliche Situation bist, kannst du das auch irgendwie festhalten, um zu wissen, auch wenn es immer nicht so gut ist, kannst du dich daran erinnern und hast einfach faktisch Beweise, dass es schon mal besser war und dass du in dem gleichen Kontext, in der gleichen Situation schon mal sehr glücklich warst. Ist dann uncool, wenn du merkst, dass es drastisch bergab geht jeden Monat und es mal ganz geil war und noch schon mal wesentlich cooler und noch cooler als das. Aber ja, ich verstehe schon, was du meinst. Übrigens jetzt auf der Puffopedia eine Liste geschrieben von allen Frauen, die wir schon beleidigt haben im Podcast. Das heißt, ihr könnt euch da, falls ihr den Namen eurer Freundin findet, könntet ihr hier schon mal die Nachricht absenden. Aber auch positive Sachen, die wir über Frauen gesagt haben mit Namen, könnt ihr euch da runterladen auf der Pufopedia-Seite Mädchen und Frauen. Könnt ihr dort alles anschauen. Viel Spaß dabei. Ich hoffe, der unser neu eingestellter Programmierer hört das jetzt mit.
Wir haben wirklich, wir haben echt einen Programmierer eingestellt.
Wir haben tatsächlich, Pufopedia ist auf dem Weg der Besserung.
Kriegt der Geld dafür? Ja. Ach so. Also halt ein T-Shirt. Kauft nicht mal mehr T-Shirts, Leute. Ey, was ist denn da los? Die Leute kaufen überhaupt keine T-Shirts mehr. Aber die sind scheiße. Uns haben schon mal Leute geschrieben, dass sie gerne was kaufen würden, aber die sind hässlich. Vielleicht gibt es da ja bald ein Neujahr. Wie schön wär das denn? Aber wie gesagt, wenn euch die T-Shirts nicht gefallen, dann kauft einfach mehr davon und habt einfach mal, wenn die schnell kaputt gehen, kauft gleich ein neues. Kauft sie auf, dass wir gezwungen sind, neue zu schreiben, neue zu machen, neue zu gestalten. Das ist keine schlechte Idee. Ja, ja, ja. Ansonsten, wir haben noch ganz viele Messages bekommen, ich kann sie leider nicht darauf zugreifen, weil das Internet leider gerade sehr, sehr schwach ist.
Aber wie gesagt, wirklich, Kevin, schreibt mal,
wie es gerade momentan läuft.
Und holy shit.
Haben wir noch Zeit? Wir zahlen die Reisekosten,
du kommst hierher und wir bereden den Fall
und wir kriegen Hannah zurück.
Make Hannah great again, 2016.
Wir kriegen das hin.
Hallo, Föhrendchen und Stefan, ich bin einer der weiblichen aus Italien kommenden Zuhörer. Noch einer, ich bin erst durch das, naja, hast du eben vorgelesen. Sehr gut, wie viele Punkte hattest du noch mal in Co-Moderation bei deiner Moderationsklausur? In der Moderation, das ist etwas ganz Neues für mich gerade, Co-Moderation. Ja stimmt, ist natürlich schwer reinzukommen. Emilia schreibt noch, Emilia schreibt noch. Oh ja, Emilia hat uns einen tollen Ausschnitt geschickt. Ich weiß nicht genau, worauf das hinausläuft, aber wir gehen einfach mal drauf ein. Emilia schreibt, liebes Podcast-Ufo, ich höre leidenschaftlich euren Podcast, bin aber erst bei Folge 27, also nicht auf dem neuesten Stand. Trotzdem will ich euch auch noch schicken. Du wirst noch durch viele gute und viel mehr schlechte Folgen gehen. Dieser Artikel aus dem Tagesspiegel hängt schon mindestens seit einem Jahr bei mir an der Wand und ich finde ihn einfach toll. Falls ihr euch beruflich einmal neu orientieren wollt, könnt ihr euch ja inspirieren lassen. Sie hat das Bild eines Artikels angehängt. Wir können mal reinschauen. Wollen wir in den verteilten Rollen lesen? Das ist glaube ich ein Interview, oder? Ist ein Interview, ja. Okay. Also, wir lesen hier das Interview aus dem Tagesspiegel mit der Überschrift Niemand darf weinen und es heißt hier in der zweiten Überschrift der Leiter des Gruselkabinetts über die Kunst des Erschreckens und sein Casting. Herr Lenz, Sie suchen einen Erschrecker fürs Gruselkabinett. Was müssen die Kandidaten im Casting alles machen? Na ja, sie müssen zeigen, dass sie ordentlich schreien können. Außerdem gucken wir, wer am schönsten stirbt. Die Kandidaten müssen im Casting mit Geistern und Dämonen kommunizieren und zehn Liegestütze machen. Wieso Liegestütze? Ein Erschrecker braucht eine Top-Kondition. In dem Beruf rennt man wahnsinnig viel und dabei muss man ruhig bleiben können. Ein Erschrecker muss sich schnell anschleichen, ohne aufzufallen. Dann schlägt er zu mit Röcheln, mit Grunzen, Schreien, aber kein Buu wie in der Kindergeisterbahn. Das muss bis aufs Mark erschrecken, danach gilt es wieder unauffällig, in eine Ecke zu verschwinden. Wir suchen Leute, die zwischen den zwei extremen Ruhe und Action hin und her wechseln können. Wie weit darf der Erschrecker denn gehen? Der Erschrecker muss böse und grimmig sein, aber grundsätzlich suchen wir einen lieben Charakter. Die Erschrecker dürfen auch nicht zu weit gehen. Wenn Kinder anfangen zu weinen, ist das nicht in Ordnung. Bei Erwachsenen kann das okay sein. Die kommen ja her, um sich zu gruseln und wollen Entertainment. Trotzdem dürfen die Erschrecker nicht so weit gehen, dass die Besucher am Abend nicht mehr einschlafen können. Und was bitte soll Kommunikation mit Geistern und Dämonen sein? Das war dieser leicht aggressive Ton. Und was zur Hölle soll Kommunikation und Geistern sein? Wir suchen jemanden, der im Erschrecker-Team kommunizieren kann. Paul, die Blonde darüber, schreit gut, erschreckt die mal. Das geht natürlich nicht. Im Team kann man zum Beispiel Grunzen oder Affengeräusche machen, um sich zu verständigen. Da sollen die Bewerber einige gute Ideen liefern. Wir gucken dann, ob die Leute im richtigen Format denken. Wer wird beim Casting erschreckt? Das ist ein toller Interview. Unser dienstältester Erschrecker sitzt in der Jury, er arbeitet seit acht Jahren hier, außerdem Horrorexpertin Jay, die ist für die Deko zuständig und ich. Wenn wir uns erschrecken, ist das natürlich exzellent, sonst erschrecken die Bewerber einfach sich hin. Oder wir testen Besucher. Wie gut ist das denn? Das ist der perfekte Sketch ohne Scheiß.
Alter, erschrecken Sie einfach mal vor sich hin. Suche Sie denn einen bestimmten Erschreckertypen. Die Bewerber sollen ihre eigenen Rollen verkörpern, jeder hat seinen eigenen Stil, sag ich mal. Wir haben hier einen Clown, einen Sensenmann, einen Gorilla, jemanden aus der Zombie-Apokalypse. Wir nehmen jemanden aus der Zombie. Aber auch keinen Zombie, sondern irgendeinen random Typen. Auch jemanden. Wir nehmen Horrorkellner oder Warzenschweine, ganz egal. Hauptsache die Bewerber bringen rüber, dass sie gruselig sind. Sie müssen ihr eigenes Kostüm mitbringen. Wie viel verdient man als Erschrecker? Bei uns arbeitet man ausschliesslich, nicht ausschliesslich als Erschrecker. Das wäre viel zu anstrengend. Wir haben hier auch noch den Souvenirladen. Ich bin Erschrecker und Souvenirladen. Man kann von dem Verdienst normal leben in Berlin, ähnlich wie im Einzelhandel. Das ist kein Studentenjob, sondern ein richtiger Beruf. Wow. Man arbeitet bei uns als Erschrecker und Glasbläser. Das ist sehr interessant. Fragen gestellt an Enno Lenze, ist Geschäftsführer des Berlin Story Verlags und betreibt das Gruselkabinett am Anhalter Bahnhof in Kreuzberg. Da sucht er gerade neue Erschrecker. Ey, aber was für ein patziges, schreckliches Interview. Wie gut ist das? Das ist sehr lustig. Wow, aber als Erschrecker, ich habe mir das echt... Aber ich finde diese Castingszene, finde ich so sketchworthy. Das ist echt nicht schlecht, ja. Vor allem, du hast Leute da, die stellen jemanden ein, der erschreckt, aber die wollen auch, dass man erschreckt. Wie willst du jemanden erschrecken, wenn alle in dem Raum davon ausgehen, jetzt erschreckt zu werden? Damit rechnen, dass du sie jetzt erschreckst, ja. Und dann schleichst du dich so in so einem ganz hellen Castingraum, schleichst du dich so hinter die Jury und dann so... Das Glücklichste wäre, wenn du einfach aussiehst wie die Tapete in dem Raum und dann einfach plötzlich anfängst. Oder so, und der Nächste bitte und du fällst so von der Decke runter und sieh drauf irgendwie so ein mega Streber. Wie ein Kieselstein verkleidet. Das ist nicht schlecht. Ja, weil falls ihr solche tollen Sketche-Ideen von unseren Hörern geklaut sehen wollt, könnt ihr nächstes Mal bei Gute Arbeit und Wünsche jetzt vorbeischauen. Übrigens, wir können es ja auflösen. Wir machen eine lustige Comedy. Wir machen jede Woche Sketche, Sketche, Sketche, funny, funny Stuff auf Gute Arbeit Originals. Wie auf YouTube und Gute Arbeit Originals und auf Facebook habt ihr wahrscheinlich alle schon gesehen, bla bla. So, aber da könnt ihr uns weiter. Und auch Stefan Tingo ist dort angekommen als Autor. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt auch offiziell, können wir auflösen, aus dem Neo Magazin raus. Ja, erstmal, erstmal. Stefan Titzel auch. Pause. Wir legen ein kleines Neo-Magazin-Sabbatjahr ein, um jetzt ein bisschen gute Arbeit da vorne zu pushen mit Funny Gags. Auf jeden Fall. Viel Spaß, ihr könnt schon mal direkt abonnieren. Ansonsten wünsche ich euch noch eine fantastische Woche. Ich auch. Viel Spaß und Freude. Du, ich wünsche auch dir eine fantastische Woche. Wir schauen mal, vielleicht haben wir nächste Woche wieder einen fantastischen Gast. Oder einfach nur einen Gast. Ansonsten immer natürlich gerne Post von euch und ansonsten Kommentare, wie ihr ihn nennen.
Vielen Dank, Stefan Titzel, für diese fantastische, ich muss los.
Vielen Dank für diese Folge, hau rein, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschaui, Leute, haut rein, macht's gut, tschüss.